is my question to you Andrew Scott was
that you driving it's so humid you drive
I don't drive looking for a friend
it's one of the most humiliating things
because when you don't drive there they
get quite worried because it's all
insurance and when you're playing in a
driver you're very good in it they sort
of try to help you and then they sort of
have to assume that you're just
completely ignorant like you know a
steering wheel that's a radio grab over
and then they put you on what can only
be described as sort of like a massive
skateboard the car the whole car and
then they sort of try you know act so
you've never sort of you know you love
technology so you must love black mirror
and all the things but I think it's
brilliant yeah he's a genius jobrooker
and and actually the solution is not far
around the corner because even when I'm
in America I I have a Tesla and it
drives itself so it has an autonomous
mode so it's wonderful and you have
friends you can scare the living
daylights out by being on the freeway
and then you know they didn't see you
you just pull the stalk back three times
to go into Auto Drive and then you just
think now I can be bothered
another one you can do as well good
trick is is if someone if your passenger
falls asleep which I hate because you've
got to do the driving there's no one to
talk to
I'd to the start waking up again and I
close my left eye they absolutely
[Laughter]
[Music]
you